the movie is based on a true story the
opening scene begins with our main
character Alvaro sitting with his
ex-girlfriend Ona on a beach Anna on a
beach it appears that he loves her a lot
and regrets their past misunderstandings
when Ona inquires about why he brought
her here he begins to describe the Fatal
incident he experienced in this exact
location the scene then cuts to a
flashback where Alvaro and several of
his friends arrive at a secluded Island
they surf the entire day and have the
time of their Liv turns out Alvaro and
his best friend Neo are professional
Surfers and they regularly go on such
outings at night they set up camp near
the beach and have a grand party Neo
then gathers his close friends near a
bonfire and reveals something important
he says that he is moving to Canada very
soon because he now has a special person
in his life and it's not a moose she has
recently become pregnant so he plans to
settle down with her upon hearing this
all of nilo's friends are happy for him
except for Alvar he is clearly upset but
doesn't say anything for the moment as
the conversation wears on Alvaro notices
his ex-girlfriend Ona dancing with
another man it is revealed that the two
recently broke up because of his
infidelity and lies he is still head
over heels for her but Ona has already
moved on Alvaro then approaches the guy
and picks a fight with him what's up bro
you want to go but before things can
escalate the others quickly intervene
and separate them in the next scene Neo
takes Alvaro to a quiet place to talk
privately he knows that his friend is
upset about something and he wants to
know why Alvaro then brings up the
promise they had made when they were
teenagers they had vowed to travel the
world and surf together but now neilo is
breaking that promise and leaving for
good neilo apologizes for the sudden
decision and shares that he loves his
girlfriend a lot since he is about to be
a father he wants to be there for her
hearing this Alvaro finally understands
him and wishes him a bright future he
also gives him two plane tickets to
Indonesia so that he can enjoy his
honeymoon there it is revealed that
Alvaro had bought the tickets for them
to Surf there but now that neilo is
leaving he doesn't want to go anymore
early the next morning Alvaro drives off
to the other side of the island he is
having a bad headache due to last
night's drinking session but he shrugs
it off and proceeds to do what he loves
the most surfing along the way he gets
multiple messages from his co-workers
Neo as well as his family members his
sister points out that today is her
birthday and advises him to make the
occasional call home because his mother
often misses him however Alvaro does not
respond to any of the messages or calls
he then abandons his vehicle and starts
walking towards the beach with his
surfboard and backpack Alvaro is
listening to some music on his airpods
so he doesn't realize that the sand
beneath him is slippery why does he need
his ears for slippery the land is also
very steep which makes the walk
difficult unfortunately Alvaro slips at
the wrong moment causing him to slowly
slide down the cliff he manages to hold
on at one point but it is impossible to
climb back up due to the sand at that
moment he gets a call in his phone and
as he tries to reach for it in his
backpack he loses his grip and slides
further down Alvaro soon reaches the
Cliff's Edge and now he is holding on
for dear life when he looks down he sees
the gigantic waves and the sharp rocks
this terrifies him because if he falls
he is not going to make it Alvaro
desperately holds on with all his
strength hoping that someone will come
to his rescue but when no one shows up
for a few minutes it finally Dawns on
him that he is all alone here Alvaro
then looks down and observes the sea
waves striking the Rocks this gives him
a risky but brilliant idea he counts the
duration at which the waves strike the
rocks and learns that it is 8 seconds
fortunately eight is exactly as high as
Alvaro can count then he prays to God
and takes a daring leap at exactly 8
seconds Alvaro lands in the water but
one of his legs hits a rock and his
right hand is badly injured he somehow
manages to swim to one of the rocks and
feels relieved thinking that he is still
alive but as he tries to move forward
his fractured leg suddenly snaps this
causes him to fall and hit a rock
knocking him unconscious when Alvaro
comes to his senses he discovers that he
has injured his head and stomach there
is also a deep cut on his waist
desperate he pulls out his phone to call
for help but it has been damaged by
water as if a surfer wouldn't have a
waterproof phone he then screams for
assistance but there is no one around to
hear him when all of his attempts fail
he decides to check on his wounds he
wraps his shirt around his arm to stop
the bleeding and then tries to move his
legs Alvaro is happy that they are still
functioning but he can't move due to his
injured arm and leg tired and dizzy he
then falls asleep on the Rock when he
wakes up he is devastated to learn that
help has still not arrived so he decides
to take matters into his own hands he
observes the place carefully and decides
to swim to the other Seashore the only
problem is that Alvaro can only use one
each of his hands and legs still he
pulls on his backpack and takes a leap
into the water after paddling for a
while he feels a sharp pain in his
stomach caused by muscle spasms and
internal bleeding he tries to Bear the
pain but it does not go away by this
point he has drunk so much sea water
that he has started feeling weak when he
can't think of any solutions he gives up
on his life and begins to drown in this
state of of helplessness alvaro's life
flashes right in front of his eyes he
recalls the time spent with his
ex-girlfriend and how happy they were
then this surprisingly ignites his will
to live so he swims back up again booed
by his boner in the present Ona is in
tears after hearing all of this she
forgives him for everything he has done
in the past but says that she cannot be
with him anymore she tells him to start
his life from zero as mean and kisses
him goodbye before leaving alvara stands
up and attempts to stop her but it is
revealed that it is just his imagination
he also sees himself crawling to the
beach and when he wakes up he is lying
on the seashore 24 hours have passed and
his condition is getting worse on the
beach we see him lying down with a large
SOS message hoping that someone will
notice him he takes out some tin foil
from his bag and wraps his wound to
prevent infection after a while Alvaro
notices a surfboat floating nearby he
realizes that this may be his only
chance of getting out of here because he
is an excellent Surfer he slowly crawls
towards it but the High Tides push him
off a rock knocking him out when Alvaro
comes to his senses he finds himself
floating in the waves he is dangerously
close to the rocks and one strike can
result in his death since it is
impossible to come out by himself Alvaro
decides to use his bag as a hook
fortunately the plan works he somehow
manages to grab onto a rock and pull
himself up from the high tides in the
next scene Alvaro notices a helicopter
and this makes him somewhat excited he
uses all of his energy and tries to grab
their attention but to no avail help me
the helicopter can't hear him due to the
high tides and it soon vanishes later
while Alvaro is sleeping a cheeky
seagull approaches him thinking he's
dead it starts biting his wounds making
them even worse Alvaro quickly chases
the bird away and crawls back to the
shore he is extremely thirsty so he
starts looking around for water he
obviously doesn't find any and to make
matters worse his hand is poked by a
fishing hook Alvaro doesn't know how to
stop the bleeding so he applies some
sand to it after that he urinates on a
piece of tin foil to drink it but fails
because it mostly contains blood the
temperature drops at night so Alvaro
wraps himself in tin foil into fishing
net to protect himself from the cold
after a while he notices lightning and
thunder in the sky this causes that
awful Imagine Dragon song to get stuck
in his head and he wants to end it all
but it also makes him hopeful that he
will soon be able to drink some water
however his bad luck manifests as the
rain stops only after a few drops
helpless Alvaro goes back to sleep and
prays to God saying I don't want to die
the following morning he is awoken by
the sudden ringing on his phone he looks
for it everywhere but fails to find it
when the ringing persists he realizes
that it is buried in the sand so he
starts digging and eventually finds his
cell phone Alvaro notices that his
parents have video called him so he
immediately answers it even though it'll
kill the battery he then explains
everything that has happened to him in
the past 36 hours but strangely the
parents are unmoved they keep talking
about irrelevant stuff at this moment
Alvaro realizes that he is hallucinating
due to his extreme thirst despite this
he speaks to his parents with tears in
his eyes and apologizes for everything
he has done in the past Alvaro also
expresses his love for them and his
belief that he will never be able to
return home later he comes across the
same surfboard and crawls towards it he
imagines himself surfing and having fun
with his friends like he did before but
in reality he is still lying down on the
beach helpless after some time Alvaro
decides to swim back to the ocean and
try to save himself one last time he
somehow gets hold of the boat and crawls
into the water but after just a few
minutes his energy drains causing him to
drown in the middle of the sea this time
Alvaro doesn't imagine things more
struggle he has accepted his fate but
before he can succumb due to the lack of
oxygen a rescue team notices his
surfboard they immediately dive into the
water and finally rescue him following
this he has flown to the hospital where
his best friend nilo visits him Alvaro
bursts out in tears and lets out
everything he had inside him he
expresses his love for his parents
something which he has rarely done
before he also discusses Ona who left
him because of his arrogant nature
Alvaro claims that no one can love him
as as much as she does but he must now
let her go even if it is painful he has
regrets about everything in his life but
he must persevere and walk through it
later Ona also pays him a visit making
him very happy in the final scene the
real Alvaro is shown standing on a cliff
gazing at the vast sea according to
reports he was rescued after 48 Hours of
being stranded in other words he has
nothing on James Franco subscribe for
more videos like this turn turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching